peut-être l'un d'autres personnes que ça
dérange même savoir avec un mec ça ça
arrive déjà toutes les filles
[Musique]
ouais sans quelque part un peu déçu
ricky martin
[Applaudissements]
le mec de prison break
maintenant alex ramirès non
ils défendront donc tous
oui le mec de la série prison break si
vous saviez pas
il est dans notre équipe
enfin je dis ça et certaines suites leur
dicte avec amex a produit la réaction
totalement inverse 1 elles sont comme
des dingues sa taille est trop mignon
trop mignon de quoi on n'est pas des
chatons [ __ ]
puis c'est quoi cette phrase j'adore les
gainante alors les smoothies les champs
pain sec et à l'évidence dire des
conneries tu peux pas aimer tous les
gains de manière absolue on n'est pas
des nems coiffant tu vois
même et a bien compris en fait j'adore
les gaines à ce que ce truc est illégal
c'est toujours marrant d'être sûr de
l'animal une source à la fête où on est
des bouffons quoi
ouais on est là pour se divertir voilà
quand tu as envie de tout est ok on est
là pour faire la guerre sauf ma grande
honte sert qu'à ça
[Applaudissements]
et
oui c'est vos impôts on est payé par la
ville en dessous
tout cas et certaines filles que ça
libère complètement du coup je fais me
déshabiller devant toi ça dérange pas
qu'est ce que tu viens de dire que
dérangeant
surtout quand on est dans la rue
alors je parle de certaines filles mais
a surtout certains mecs qui peuvent pas
s'empêcher de tout ramener à ça ça lui
enchanté alex pas [ __ ]
alors déjà vu ta gueule
palenfo que je voulais
je comprends pas encore aujourd'hui
c'est cette peur ancestrale qui autour
des gay comme si on passait nos soirées
dans des labos secrets à élaborer des
plans machiavéliques pour convertir tous
les hétéros
et quand il se penchera pour ramasser
son stylo feutre bim
et brillant brillant
[Applaudissements]